good evening good evening ladies and
gentlemen
my name is Laura Wegman and I'm a junior
here at Hillsdale College I am double
majoring in American Studies in fine art
and it is my distinct privilege to
introduce tonight's speaker mr. Forbes
Stephen Forbes is chairman and chief
executive officer of Forbes media as
well as editor-in-chief of Forbes
magazine a graduate of Princeton
University President Reagan named mr.
Forbes chairman of the board for
international broadcasting in 1985 in
which position he oversaw the operation
of Radio Free Europe and Radio Liberty
he campaigned for the Republican
nomination for the presidency in 1996
and 2000 he serves on the boards of the
Ronald Reagan Presidential Foundation
the Heritage Foundation and the
foundation for the defense of
democracies he's on the board of
overseers of the Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center on the
Board of Visitors for the School of
Public Policy at Pepperdine University
his books include flat-tax revolution
using a postcard to abolish the IRS and
how capitalism will save us by free
people and free markets are the best
answers in today's economy co-authored
with Elizabeth Eames ladies and
gentlemen will you please join me in
welcoming mr. Stephen Forbes
thank you
well thank you very very much Laura and
thank all of you for a very warm welcome
it is good to be back at Hillsdale which
sometimes in these turbulent times feels
like what a monastery must have felt
like during the dark ages
you know quite quite place of
enlightenment but it is and also even
the also delighted to get a free dinner
not quite the same as a free lunch but
you take take what you can and but I've
been asked tonight to make some remarks
about the Great Society and where we're
at today and where we go from here with
that legacy as you learned earlier from
Jonah where the Great Society and he hit
on the early 60s the Great Society
really should be called the great hubris
there was a it's true there is a really
a feeling in that time that man and
government could solve every problem
remove every risk banished every woe as
long as you had the experts running
things and it was sort of a combining in
a perverse way American can-do ISM with
the power of big government but as the
founders could have told him that is not
a good formula but nonetheless they
thought they could create a utopia and
some of you I don't think any of you are
old enough I'm alone old enough to
remember back in the 60s when we put a
man that's you know
yes it's called pandering
I tried it in politics didn't work which
is why I'm here tonight but but back
back back back in the 60s with the
Apollo program getting a man on the moon
I can't tell you how many times you
heard the phrase if we can put a man in
the moon we can clear the slums that's
what they called the inner city in those
days if we can put a man in the moon we
can have everyone employed we can do
this we can do that so as it was part of
the era and so and even in warfare the
early part of Vietnam war when they're
escalating the war McNamara the defense
secretary I was really into numbers wonk
ISM gave wonka's him a bad name if they
had the name then and and he really felt
that if you scientifically increase the
pressure on North Vietnam they would
cave and so this wasn't done on how you
fight insurgencies this wasn't done to
meet the peculiarities or particularity
z' of that particular region which in
2006 we finally started to do in Iraq
which is why we won there after nearly
losing it that was not done in the night
in late 1960s so in warfare they thought
they could apply this kind of
quantitative approach of getting rid of
slums as they call in the inner cities
which urban renewal which became known
as urban removal and you saw what
happened with the so-called public
housing turned out to be disastrous
because they weren't natural but the
wonderful phrases they use like acres in
the sky houses in the sky really giddy
stuff but disasters they all thought
they could save the developing world by
applying more money more so-called
American know-how some of you may
remember the only sixties when John
Kennedy came in the Alliance for
Progress is gonna save Latin America
that didn't end but they thought they
could eradicate disease hence the war on
cancer eradicate poverty hence the war
on poverty Soviet Union even there was a
period of time when they had the thing
called convergence that you know we're
gonna become more big government they're
gonna become less big government that
they actually believe this stuff in
those days so it was sort of an early
version of the end of history and the
economy they thought that they could get
rid of ups and downs in the economy
eradicate them they thought they could
tame the business cycle
they thought that free markets were
inherently unstable that if you didn't
have a strong government guiding the
thing free markets would go off the
rails as it did allegedly in the Great
Depression so government would be like
an automobile you would step on the
pedal of things getting too slow
put on the brakes from things are
getting too hot is if they knew whether
the economy we hear the phrase today
overheating or underperforming and so
Keynes John Maynard Keynes actually
thought how blissful would be if
economic policy was set by a group of
wise men this is before women got more
power but he called it wise men and just
just make that clear I have five
daughters so I'm gonna be careful on
these things but but but he really
thought that you could have an
environment where a handful of people
who know knew more than everybody else
could guide in a very precise and
scientific way the economy and make sure
it stayed on an even keel and he
disdained gold you know as a barbarous
relic who needs that you know people
with the right facts can deal with the
money and he saw to in monetarism there
was the feeling that monetarism you
control the money supply you can
eradicate the business cycle and in that
sense and I'm being blunt here
Keynesianism and monetarism that time
was really two sides of the same coin so
was is when they're sort of a scientific
version of philosopher of Kings they
could do it better than messiness of
politics and free markets as you know
the Progressive Era in this country
thought that government had become
inefficient that the checks and balances
the Constitution were antique and
archaic and standing in the way of
progress so if you had experts using
scientific methods above the political
fray they could bring about heaven on
earth there was another aspect and how
this came about it wasn't just ideas
suddenly taking over this is something
that both liberals and conservatives a
little bit squirmish about and that is
warfare as you know from history major
Wars bring about big increases in
government power that's why he got the
absolute monarchies in France and Spain
that's why he didn't get it in Britain
because they were not part of the
continent so they had a small military
big Navy but small military
in this country we had a tradition a
very very small national government
deliberately designed for most of the
19th century the only time you'd have a
run-in with the federal government was
at the post office and the major
exception of course was a civil war
massive increase in government powers
but after the Civil War
income tax eventually eradicated
government powers ramped down and then
World War one enormous increase in
government power but after World War one
the tradition hitting in again in the
1920s government spending was slashed
taxes were slashed from wartime rates
income taxes cut from a high of 77
percent down to 25 percent actual
government spending was reduced from
what it was at the beginning of that
decade and the national debt was reduced
by over a third particularly under the
push of Calvin Coolidge whose reputation
is now going up but what happened why in
the world do we have the Leviathan that
we have today
well first came the Great Depression and
activist President Herbert Hoover as you
know the myth is that he was a
do-nothing president actually he was a
due to too much president it was the
smoot-hawley Tariff that helped
initially bring on that disaster if you
follow the course of that legislation in
1929 1930 every time that legislation
looked like it might pass putting on
massive tax increases on imports every
time it looked like it might pass the
stock market crashed especially in the
fall of 1929 when it looked like it
might be sidetracked in the sausage
factory of Congress stock market came up
by the end of 1929 many stocks are at
the same level as they were at the
beginning of 29 and smoot-hawley came
back again and the rest of destroyed the
global trading system destroyed then the
flow of global capital massive trade war
global depression had it Hoover respond
to this heat old big companies don't cut
your wages that sounds like a nice thing
amazingly they agreed to it and didn't
for over a year but how did they how did
they cope when their sales plummeted
while they put the pressure on their
suppliers and the suppliers took the hit
it didn't work as if all of that wasn't
enough in the 1931 Hoover concluded that
the budget was an imbalance no surprise
when you have a depression government
receipts plummet
he thought he could restore confidence
by putting in a huge tax increase and a
restoring confidence Congress amazingly
went along and so unemployment went from
15 percent to 25 percent they raised the
top income tax rate from 25% to 63% they
put on excise taxes everywhere including
a stamp tax you thought we didn't have
stamped taxes after the Revolutionary
period pre-revolutionary war that came
back on checks you wrote a check you
paid a fee of government tax so guess
what happened since why why pay at
government tax writing a check people
withdrew cash from the banks and that
put a lower pressure on our already
weakened banking system so Hoover
brought it on but nonetheless was
declared to be a massive failure of a
free of of free markets and so you had a
full disaster there which meant when if
Hoover brought on more power Roosevelt
comes in with a new deal massive
increase in federal power in peacetime
the people especially came in with
Roosevelt were intoxicated by the power
they had briefly in World War one after
all in a world war you have to mobilize
all resources government took over the
post office took over the telephone
companies huge increase and as I
mentioned after the war it was ramped
down but that experience led a lot of
people to think by golly if we could win
a war by having a massive central
government I can't think of all the
glorious things we can do in peacetime
and so when the New Deal came in we had
the closest thing to the F word that was
discussed earlier with a liberal in
front of it in a Jonas book in terms of
terms of the corporate state with the
NRA National Recovery administration
where you had codes of conduct for
businesses
you had to you're told what you could
pay told the price you could charge and
you went to jail if you violated those
codes including numerous stories a
Maneesh laser recounts
of a tailor undercharging for what it
cost to proclaim and press a shirt went
to jail for it because it wasn't
charging enough thankfully the Supreme
Court and one of its last great acts
threw it out in the 1935 Roosevelt
browbeat the courts and as a result even
though he couldn't pack the courts it's
only now that the first time I think the
courts in terms of the economic area is
finally going to go back to the
Constitution because since the 1930s
even when they sort of knew the
government wasn't doing things that it
shouldn't be doing things that was doing
they backed off from it example was of
course GM and Chrysler especially in the
case of Chrysler in early 2009 tearing
up contracts like that that should have
been taken on by the courts and declared
unconstitutional declared illegal they
took a pass on it but I think with this
individual mandate from Obamacare that
is getting a serious look that would not
have happened a year or two ago so
things are thankfully beginning to move
back but in terms of in terms of power
the power then the world by the end of
the 1930s the New Deal had been
discredited they'd taken a huge hit in
the 1938 elections Roosevelt was
repudiated even by his own party when he
tried to purge members who weren't going
along with this program he lost most of
those primaries then of course came the
Second World War
huge ramped up in power absolutely
necessary to preserve ourselves in
civilization so what happened after
World War 2 power declined again big
cuts in government spending to spite the
best efforts of Harry Truman taxes were
cut excise taxes especially were cut
even even the income taxes cut a little
bit wartime controls were removed
economists thought too precipitously but
by golly they were removed and what
happened did we have a depression no the
economy got better
ten million veterans 12 million veterans
comeback economy absorbs them
unemployment never approached 6% till
1949 so look like we're gonna get back
on track again
after the Great Depression the
experience of the Second World War then
of course came but
Cold War another mammoth increase in
government to fight that thing and then
war became a motif
hence the war on poverty hence the war
on disease war on cancer war on drugs
even the national highway program
interstate highway program in the 1950s
was justified in terms of national
security so the government grew again
and have became Oh even after the end of
the Cold War no one had the appetite to
really ramp the thing back Ronald Reagan
helped end the Cold War hadn't been for
him we would not have won the Cold War
the way we did but he was out of office
when that thing was finally achieved and
who those who succeeded him did not have
his desire to reduce the size of the
Leviathan so but if you look back at the
Great Society the great hubris look
where we are today in terms of the Great
Society it's hard to pinpoint anything
that it did ultimately really right
other than the Civil Rights Act of 1964
and the Voting Rights Act in early 1965
almost everything else was a failure on
the economic side the 1970s after we got
rid of the gold standard under
Republican Richard Nixon finally killed
the thing but the intellectual thinking
was all against gold have floating rates
and the like had a terrible decade of
inflation massive unemployment as you
know by the early 1980s before reagan's
reform programs kicked in unemployment
was higher than even it is today 21%
interest rates 18% mortgage rates a
stock market in real terms down 60% from
what it was fifteen years before
bellyache about the market today
imagine a 15-year bear market had plenty
of rallies in between but in real terms
economists call the trendline a disaster
so poverty do we get rid of poverty no
in fact what happened you got poverty
groups created groups funded by the
government to help poor people and it
was amazing groups like acorn is the
most notorious one but their scores of
those groups out there imagine using
government money to lobby the government
for more power more regulations and more
money talk about the ultimate perpetual
motion machine this is it we give you
money you can use it to lobby for more
money whoa and so and so what no
surprised welfare exploded
they thought it was humane to put people
on welfare blighted millions of lives
courage family breakdown crime drug use
went up terms of the economy itself the
ups and downs became more violent not
less violent and what happened in terms
of the economy the economy is so weak by
the end of the 1970s before Reagan came
in that people thought as some do today
the United States was in an irreversible
decline and so it's not just economics
not just material prosperity when the
United States is perceived as weak bad
things happen in the rest of the world
and we're still paying the price look at
Iran some other things still paying the
price for it today so Reagan's reforms
come in we have a 20 year plus boom he
reduced tax rates
killed the terrible inflation of the
1970s won the Cold War
deregulation started under Jimmy Carter
but he really pushed at Ronald Reagan to
take Airlines if today you know you may
pay a hundred 200 bucks for a ticket to
go somewhere equivalent 30 years ago
would have been one thousand two
thousand dollars they didn't complete it
which is why you have all this backup at
airports because the air traffic control
was not deregulated so we're still using
obsolete technology there if technology
was up-to-date in air traffic control it
could handle two to three times the
amount of a airline traffic that it does
today so the job wasn't complete but in
railroads they did a good job at
deregulation railroads are going bust in
the 70s going bankrupt government to
take over Conrail the old Pennsylvania
Railroad
when was deregulated in the early 80s
Gavin free game flexibility to charge
what they wanted to merge how they
wanted railroads revived their booming
today and as a result today the United
States in terms of moving Freight has
the most efficient system in the world
people say why don't we do more from
moving passengers by rail the thing is
when you have a rail system it can do
one of two things can move passengers or
Freight it cannot do both the track of
the track that can handle Freight
efficiently is not good for high speed
rails you have one or the other if you
want to remove passengers you have to
build a whole rail system which costs
tens of billions of dollars and even in
Europe which they've been pushing this
for decades only six percent of European
passenger traffic is moved by rails
despite massive subsidies and efforts to
get people off the roads it just does
not work in a modern economy in
high-density areas like parts of the
East Coast it does work for much of the
country if manifestly does not work but
the here thing is though for on the rare
times in history government agencies
ceased to exist the Civil Aeronautics
Board the Interstate Commerce Commission
they ceased to exist with the these kind
of d regulations so the Great Society
the problem of the Great Society and
what preceded it that impulse was they
forgot about even their two successes in
civil rights civil rights advanced in
this country not because the government
decreed that it must happen it happened
because citizens people like Martin
Luther King jr. changed public opinion
about civil rights so on the law was
passed in 1964 it had the full assent of
most of this country remember the 14th
and 15th amendments had been passed
after the Civil War
read them boy that's great stuff but
they were dead letters because public
opinion was not supportive of it so was
the groundwork laid by the civil rights
movement groundwork laid by men like
Martin Luther King jr. it made it
possible for not only those bills to
pass but to become effective and have
the moral assent of the people just give
you one quick example on that because
this is so important when courts start
to think they're philosopher Kings if
you watch a movie called giant if you're
up late you have Netflix and want to
watch something you remember the scene
where they go to the restaurant after a
party or something and
yes I think the Hispanic fellow with
them and they go in the restaurant and
the restaurant tour in Texas says get
these you know what's out of here the
guy gets in a fight by 1964 when public
accommodations it was decreed by federal
law that if you serve the public you
must serve all of the public he didn't
have that kind of violent resistance she
had some resistance Georgia and
elsewhere but given the mood of the
people ten years before what was
remarkable is how well that part of the
Civil Rights Act worked but it wasn't a
decree from the government it was
because it had the moral assent of the
people people knew this was the right
thing to do and willing to have it
enforced which was not true a generation
before so it wasn't decrees from folks
on high was groundworks cut work done
day after day by civil rights leaders
that prepared the groundwork for what
happened unfortunately the wrong lessons
were learned so the Supreme Court in the
early 70s decides to be philosopher-king
and ban abortion in this country I mean
it will allow abortion now put aside
what you feel about abortion that is a
subject that should be ultimately
decided by We the People and in the
early 1970s as I'm pro-life it pains me
to say this but public opinion was in
favor of a beginning to expand the
rights to abortion he saw it in
California saw it in New York he started
seeing in other states so he might have
gone the way of Western Europe and
you're like part of a pregnancy you
could do it and it would have happened
you may not have liked it I wouldn't
have liked it but it happened in the way
that it should happen with the consent
of the people and those who when you
lose a battle a nice thing isn't a
democracy can revisit at those battles
but if it comes from a decree from the
court it poisons politics of pollutes
politics which is why these Supreme
Court fights are so fierce and nasty and
vicious because so much rides on things
that be should be settled by
legislatures by we the people instead of
unelected judges so that is
unfortunate legacy of that period you
can decree things and good things will
happen in essence what the great society
and what this government today is
forgotten at least two parts of it have
forgotten is that government is human
beings people and people means politics
people have emotions people have
interests and government has interests
the one great advantage that government
has is that it seems to be judged by
intentions while in the private sector
you're judged by results so the
government can muck up as it did for
welfare for decades education is done
still today but hey the intentions are
good say get a pass
that's judging by results and realize
big government is not some wonderful
thing it is people and it has its own
special interests for example education
K through 12 in many parts of the
country we're not keeping up with the
rest of the world and it even though the
results are bad even though a lot of
teachers who are teaching shouldn't be
teaching try to make a change it has
fiercely resisted and you get little
pockets of change one example is New
Orleans after Katrina government took
over the schools wiped out but after
Katrina
something happened Louisiana amazingly
positive and that is the government
allowed most of those schools to become
charter schools so each school could run
the school in its own way as a result
even though 84% of the kids in New
Orleans schools are from low-income
families test scores are going up if
you're a parent and don't like what the
school is doing you're not restricted by
neighborhood you send the kid to another
school a la it works
the Kipp schools read about them village
academies I'm familiar with them and
Harlem take kids starting the fifth
grade they don't cherry-pick them they
they they they they come well those who
want to come can come but the school
doesn't go out and try to pick the most
promising students
test scores zoomed in an environment
where learning is taken seriously even
if the kid comes from a household that
is not conducive to learning it can
happen in a properly functioning school
I mentioned welfare blighted tens of
millions of lives manifestly not working
was until 1996 that it came to pass and
that was from relentless pressure from a
Republican Congress and the experiment
which is what should happen in a federal
of kind of government arrangement states
can do things and see what works and
doesn't work Wisconsin led the charge in
the early 80s on welfare reform showed
you could drastically cut welfare rolls
and not have people starve to death
people could learn and get into the
workforce and so Wisconsin did it others
did it even New York City under Mayor
Rudy Giuliani when he came into office
1.1 million people on welfare rolls the
time he left was about four or five
hundred thousand in New York was not a
blighted place it prospered a lot of
those folks went to work for the
hospitality industry why were people
suddenly had need go need for
hospitality workers and hotels cuz you
fought crime reduce crime New York
became a nice place to visit
Times Square became a place where you
could walk from one end to another and
come out alive
it's amazing it's amazing so but you
government does not respond the way a
business does in the marketplace if a
business is not doing something to meet
the needs and wants of others
that's not providing the product or
service that others want guess what
happens
it fails government the force of the
government power they can go on forever
as we saw with welfare you see it today
these independent agencies which are
dubious constitutional value I'm not
sure in previous times they would have
been passed muster but they have
numerous independent agencies the
Congress love these things because they
could write laws in vague language throw
them off to these independent agencies
when something went wrong I could held
those down bureaucrats it's their fault
I can't do anything about vote for me
and and so it's shucking off a
responsibility and once you have an
agency it will fight to exist
this is human human nature even if the
need for does cease to exist it will
fight to exist
you see numerous examples Federal
Communications Commission been told by
the courts leave the internet alone you
they that's not the same as telephone
service yet what did it do over
Christmas put its claws into the
Internet Federal Trade Commission about
to do the same thing you see it in the
state level 50 public utility
Commission's having regulations on wire
lines now they're trying to find a way
to do wireless which is preposterous but
they're not gonna give it up they're not
going to give it up so bottom line is
government agencies governments are
special interests like anybody else
they're human beings like anyone else
and unlike the free markets they don't
have the instant feedback and have to
respond to the instant feedback of
people's preferences the bottom line is
in terms of the economy in terms of the
need for loss for kings
bottom line is which you never would
have heard during the Great Society
years and certainly wouldn't hear from
the White House today is that every
economic disaster in the past hundred
years and even before has as its origins
not sudden some sudden failure free
markets but massive
government mistakes Great Depression
smoot-hawley numerous regulations huge
tax increases New Deal why was that the
first time in American history in a
recovery we didn't reach the peak that
we did before the depression never
happened before or since because of the
failures of the New Deal massive
government intervention in the economy
mammatus leis and others Jim Powell and
others have chronicled the thing 1970s
huge inflation seen as a failure of
democracy seen as a failure of free
enterprise now was the Fed printing too
much money in other central banks
following that bad example cutting the
tide of gold bad things happened
government increases its powers at least
for a while and today the disaster we're
trying to cover recover from today don't
fall for the thing Oh greedy Wall Street
bankers blaming greed for this disaster
is like blaming gravity for airplane
crashes no not very helpful in
particular cases not very helpful in
this case take the Federal Reserve print
it too much money still printing too
much money you could not have had a
housing bubble the Fed hadn't printed so
much money could not have happened
Fannie and Freddie guaranteeing one and
a half trillion dollars of junk paper
government entities and other things
which I won't bore you was like
mark-to-market accounting how it was
applied brought on this disaster so yes
Wall Street a lot of bad things happened
the bottom line is if government does
its part right free markets with
sensible rules of the road will do its
part right and remember this
people aren't imperfect James Madison
was right if we're angels we would not
need laws we'd not need government
manifestly we're not angels except for
perhaps grandchildren maybe up to a
certain age and but
so so today what you see in Washington
is what is truly the last stand of
statism in this country which started
really in the 1930s in peacetime the
reason I say it is look at that State of
the Union address on paper the president
looked like he was moving to the center
what does that tell you did Ronald
Reagan to advance his principles his
programs as policies have to use ultra
left-liberal language why does this guy
suddenly feel he has to use semi
conservative centrist language because
he knows the American people aren't on
the same page as he is he is a statist
even that State of the Union address I
mean I'm surprised well maybe it's
because it happened in January forgive
him that December he would have gotten a
nomination for Oscar for Best Actor
because seriously you know when you
start to parse that thing he talks about
the crazy salmon regulation at the same
time that his agencies are still pushing
ahead with massive regulation he talks
about need for Tax Simplification but
yet says we gotta raise taxes on the
rich
that's not Tax Simplification so you go
through the thing even in Afghanistan he
praises our troops in a way that Ronald
Reagan would have loved but then says
well we're gonna start withdrawing
troops in July but that what does that
tell to your enemies you can wait us out
you can wait this guy out so the tone
was one thing
Reagan s rhetoric but socialist
substance and I use that word very
carefully big battles though are coming
even though the public opinion is
against what is happening it's not going
to happen automatically fortunately
people learn from examples one of the
things that is seminal in this age is
what's happened in Greece people can see
government even if it's relatively small
one can go off the rails and disaster
can happen and we're not immune to that
either one little factoid on Greece ever
had a cocktail party among other things
they have a national railway system
revenues carry passengers revenues 130
million dollars a year expenses expenses
900 million dollars a year and experts
have figured experts have figured that
if they shut down the railway system
gave everyone free cab fare it saved
money that's so this is why this is why
it's going to take a hard work to
finally get us back on the track that
our founders put us and that events of
the last century manifestly have pushed
us off and that is President Obama give
him credit in his mind is one of the
most successful presidents in the first
two years in American history I
mentioned Roosevelt a lot of his stuff
got thrown out by the courts but see
from the way this man sees it by his
lights he's achieved great things in
terms of having government dominate or
control the economy you know socialism
has always been defined as government
owning the means of production blah blah
blah
well the East has learned long ago other
people like him have learned you don't
have to own something to control it if
you control it by regulation if their
existence depends on your dictates your
beneficence that's even better than
nationalizing them because when things
go wrong you blame the health insurance
company you don't blame the man in the
White House so look what they did in
health care it's a virtual de-facto
takeover coming in slow motion over the
next four years
but already health insurance companies
are learning they better band together
the government loves that because big
things are easier to regulate and
control they're gonna be told what they
can charge what they can offer
who gets health care who doesn't one of
the things they put in this health care
bill is destroying what they call
MiniMed insurance which is health
insurance and some basic stuff for
low-income workers transient workers
remember a couple of months ago
McDonald's was leaked that McDonald's is
gonna have to withdraw from 30,000 of
its workers because of the crazy way
they did this bill in terms of a loss
ratios medical loss ratios and won't
birth the specifics
well when that hullabaloo came up
McDonald's got a waiver what's the
criteria for waiver but only for one
year which means they have to come back
again keep them in check how do they
determine the waiver it's up to them
they've issued now hundreds of waivers
mostly to unions but that is power they
get to decide who can survive and who
perishes something hasn't gotten much
attention so-called financial reform
bill same thing deliberately vague
language the industry still doesn't know
what it is
but it means they get to control it
without owning it you have to go to them
to determine what to do and the they say
this will help fight too big to fail no
it pur it codifies it because under
systemic risk they can do anything they
want they can come and say Larry
Hillsdale proposes stomach risk you
handle money therefore you come under
our purview we got to take you over
sorry it's for the greater good they can
do that so it's gonna be all fought out
in the courts which is time which means
things become settled and it's very hard
becomes in their minds very hard to
reverse energy they try to do with this
thing called cap-and-trade big tax
increases control the inner energy
industry de facto well Congress didn't
go along with it and the people caught
on the EPA was gonna try to dictate it
so what do you do people are catching on
to what you're trying to do why you do
what the president did in the State of
the Union address talk about the need
for green energy sounds benign green you
know especially money on people like
green but by 2035 he says 80% of energy
in this country must come from renewable
resources which means massive government
control and regulation to areas where
you can get really good renewable
resources and do so cheaply nuclear
power president says White House says
well they like nuclear power try getting
all the approvals so yes but they make
it impossible very difficult for it to
come to pass so they block off that
source
another big one in this country is
natural gas thanks to hydraulic
fracturing which properly done means
massive increases in the production of
natural gas we're going to become the
Saudi Arabia of natural gas and if ten
years we'll be exporting natural gas
that's why the price is so cheap today
down almost 70 percent from what it was
just two years ago people know this is a
big thing coming which makes it viable
to have trucks use it not by diktat from
government just because it you can put
in the infrastructure no this thing this
the supply is there and the price is
right so they're gonna make it very
difficult to do hydraulic fracturing so
it's gonna poison your water wells well
if done wrong yeah it'll do it like
anything you drive wrongly we're gonna
have a bloodbath but it doesn't mean you
ban cars figure out how to do it right
so through vague language through vague
language comes power and spending it's
not just spending remember on spending
this important to tell your liberal
friends where does the money come from
it's not manna from heaven it's not from
Mars it comes from the we the people you
the tax it borrow it or printed which is
another form of Taxation so they love
spending why they say it stimulates the
economy it doesn't so why do they still
do it because it means power they seize
the resources to help us but they seize
the resources you see it in terms of
monetary policy loose monetary policy
form of Taxation power so this recovery
even though we're gonna have growth this
year of three and a half four percent
this is the worst recovery from a severe
recession since the Great Depression
why is it so Punk you know yes two years
ago we're going zero miles an hour now
maybe we'll get up to thirty five forty
we're capable own the hope and highway
of going sixty five seventy five so why
isn't happening let's just quickly go
down the list
monetary policy I know this is the most
boring subject in the world Federal
Reserve interest rates dollar
above you see ben bernanke nice beard
but it's it's unlike Larry but but so
monetary policy and by the way just to
give you a tip on monetary policy if you
ever find yourself on an airplane in
coach middle seat on the runway watching
your life pass away want a little bit of
elbow room talk to your seatmates about
monetary policy though they'll cut your
wide slack now the young people here
most of you are single here's another
tip on a bad date want out talk about
monetary policy and you'll never see
that person again but if you think you
think of monetary policy as you would an
automobile you know an automobile you
can have a magnificent vehicle but if
you don't have sufficient fuel you stall
too much you get the economic equivalent
of flooding the engine right amount you
have a chance to move forward same is
true with monetary policy if you don't
supply enough liquidity to meet the
needs of the marketplace legitimate
needs of the marketplace you're gonna
stall the economy if you supply too much
you get the economic equivalent flooding
the engine which is what's the feds been
doing since the early part of the last
decade that's what's been happening this
is why the Fed thrashing the dollar is
so destructive it's immoral if you get
you supply your labor you get a certain
amount of dollars in return that should
be a fixed amount you should know that
if you decide to not buy something right
away you can buy the equivalent tomorrow
politicians shouldn't change the value
of what you get for your labor or your
investments that's what monkeying around
with the monetary whether the what the
dollar does weak dollar means weak
recovery you know they've done revisions
of our economic performance they do this
for years you know you get the GDP
number that's just the beginning they
keep revising advising and rising is get
more information in suddenly discovering
the last decade particularly
2004 stand of livings been stagnant in
this country weak dollar means less
productive investment more speculation
ultimately a lower standard of living it
happened in the 70s it's happening today
so think of it this way
imagine if Washington did to the hour
what it did does to the dollar you have
60 minutes in an hour tomorrow it's 48
minutes day afters thirty two next days
ninety day after that is 25 minutes
you'd soon have to have hedges
derivatives futures to figure out how
many hours you're working supposed to go
to a lecture today how long is the
lecture well is that our lecture in
Michigan our or Chinese our Japanese our
how do you convert it from an English
hour just makes life complicated keep it
simple and you know if printing money
was the way to wealth Zimbabwe and
Argentina would own the world today
think of it if printing money was the
way to wealth they should legalize
counterfeiting let everyone do it you
can have a lot of money
Oh wealth that's what the Fed is doing
it's a form of legalized counterfeiting
this is what's so important I don't want
to bore you totally on monetary policy
but the thing remember is money comes
from people doing things with one
another transactions with one another
makes it easier to do allows you to look
to the future instead of the immediate
present allows you to create capital for
investment think about three thousand
years ago if I sold a page in Forbes
magazine what would I get paid in maybe
a herd of goats some sheep maybe a camel
or two and I have to figure out how to
how do how do I turn these goats and
barter enough goats to get pcs for our
writers I mean just makes it very
complicated money makes it easier it
does wonderful things if done right so
bottom line on money I'll make this
prediction because of what we're going
through now in the next five years when
I have something that we haven't had
since the early 70s the dollar is going
to be retied to gol D it has to happen
cannot trust human beings to grow to
determine the value of money we the
people determine the value of the money
not Washington politicians so in terms
of monetary policy it's holding us back
taxes
you know the Catechism on that taxes
just don't raise revenue for the
government there also a price and a
burden tax you pay an income price you
pay for working tax on profit price you
pay for being successful tax on capital
gains the price you pay for taking risks
that work out and the proposition is a
very simple one when you lower the price
of good things like productive work
where is taking success get more of them
raise the price you get less of them so
there's talk of tax increases very very
destructive and complicated why do we
have a complicated code because it's
power you want something done you got to
go to Washington get an exemption or try
to shaft your competitors with something
it's a form of power that's why the
codes been amended 14,000 times in the
last 25 years you know Abraham Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address 272 words to find the
character the American nation
Declaration of Independence about 1500
Constitution with all the amendments
7,200 words the Bible centuries to put
together 773 thousand words federal
income tax code also tenant rules and
regulations
nine and a half million words and rising
nobody knows what's in it you don't have
to go to the Amazon to find you know if
you have a wintry night here just to go
through the code you'll whoa and and
it's a source of power it's a source of
power huge source of power and so you
know several years ago Money Magazine
did a survey took a hypothetical
family's finances gave the numbers to 46
different tax preparers ashlee prepare
the return you know if they got back 46
different returns 46 different estimates
what the family owed me thousands of
dollars difference the experts don't
know they make the living at it so I'll
make another prediction in the next five
years you starting to see it already
when the president this president talks
about Tax Simplification you know
something is stirring it's got to be
done right I prayed that his version is
the old IRS version line one what did
you make
line to send it in No
it's not what we mean it's not what we
mean by Tax Simplification we I think we
should do a simple flat tax single rate
17% generous exemptions for adults and
for kids family of four no federal
income tax on your first forty six
thousand dollars of income only
seventeen percent above that no tax on
savings no death tax you should be
allowed to leave the world unmolested by
the IRS our founders would say no
taxation without respiration
so you can see what good things can come
and on spending people get it now where
the money comes from and what it can
lead to so bottom line is on regulations
on regulations what you see is for the
first time in decades they're starting
to look at the Constitution about these
independent agencies and regulations and
the first step will be to pass a law at
any regulation that has an economic
consequence more than one hundred
million dollars has to be approved by
Congress no more hiding you're gonna be
held responsible openness if you want to
do this to the American people that'll
just be for starters let me just close
let me just close by talking about
entitlements the Social Security
Medicaid Medicare you know what's
happened there Social Security disaster
twelve trillion dollars of unfunded
liabilities depending on your
assumptions Medicare Medicaid 40 to 80
trillion dollars you look at those
numbers you look at the rise in
government debt you just might as well
slit your wrists but here's what's gonna
happen if we make it happen if we start
to get things right such the dollar such
as a tax code that does not get in our
way such as regulation curbing that
what's gonna happen is this the balance
sheet is gonna come to our rescue you
start to do a few things right what
happens you start to get more growth
which means more incomes which means
more opportunity means more government
revenue what does that do it raises the
value of assets when people start to see
a future again present value of assets
go up so you take America today if you
add up all the things you own cars
houses goldfish stocks bonds bank CD's
the whole Schmeer subtract out all your
liabilities mortgages credit card debt
personal debt leases America
households are still plus 55 trillion
dollars more than the rest of the world
put together gross assets of over 70
trillion you start to get a rise in
asset value easy to see it go up 10 or
20 trillion from that base 20 trillion
overcomes a lot of stupidity from
Washington that's that's what we did in
the early eighties when reagan's reforms
kicked in now
liability size Social Security well for
my generation forget it was not financed
right but we have enough wealth in the
nation to meet those obligations not
going to come from the trust fund it's a
fraud come from the general budget and
the thing if you want to reform that
system is don't tamper with those who
are on the system it's like a war debt
sunk cost shouldn't have done it the way
we did but we did we can live through it
key thing is for younger people put in a
new system for younger people by younger
at my age below 55 actually older than
that but maybe you hadn't noticed but
anyway younger younger people you can do
it system where you have your own
personal accounts financed by that
payroll tax or a big part of it the nice
thing about that is it's your property
not Washington politicians you turn a
liability into an asset over time with
proper rules on diversification as you
get older more of your money is to go
into short-term fixed income instruments
so if a market crashes you don't have to
worry you're well diversified this is
very conservative basic stuff you start
to create capital instead of destroy it
think of it kid gets a part-time job in
the summer they're gonna start to
accumulate money capital what does that
mean they're gonna ask they're not gonna
have being a mood for politicians to
start fooling around with it it's theirs
they earned it they created it not a
bureaucrat in Washington or a
congressperson or senator they did it
now think of it liability into an asset
and on health care in closing ask
yourself why do we have a health care
crisis in this country and the answer is
well we want more of it well think of
how strange that is in any other part
of the economy people want more of
something entrepreneurs supply it people
want more great education Larry will
tell you how to do it
suck up but anyway I'm happy to make my
host happy and and if people want more
software or apps plenty of writers out
there in California here and elsewhere
to supply them people want more cars
Detroit would be very happy to supply
them in this state so what's with
healthcare why is the demand see not as
an opportunity growth industry but oh my
god we're gonna destroy us it's the
crazy way we finance it disconnect
between providers and consumers think of
it we don't have real free markets in
healthcare we have pieces of it which is
why we still produce more new medical
devices more new medicines and the rest
of the world put together
but it's only pockets of it think of it
we grew up with this system so you don't
realize how strange it is you go to a
doctor hospital clinic and you ask in
advance what it costs now look at you
means one of two things either you're
uninsured or you're a lunatic why would
you want to know what it costs what's it
to you
you'll be like going to a restaurant
ordering a bottle of wine I don't care
what it costs that's Blue Shield's
problem what Medicaid work that out you
know so the system goes off the rail
system goes off the rails so what do you
do you bring more free enterprise into
healthcare not less take food foods more
basic than health no food no nothing now
if people have trouble getting food does
that mean the government take over the
farms if it did we'd have no more
obesity Michelle Obama have find
something else to focus on this night
because we'd be all starving to death
they tried it in Russia and China
disastrous results on this country we
allow the farmers to grow the food
private companies process the food
truckers delivered grocery stores
supermarkets restaurants others sell the
food if people have problems getting it
we have everything from food banks to
food stamps to deal with it why can't
you do the same thing in health care
allow true free enterprise how do you do
it
a few quick things and we'll get the qat
allow nationwide
shopping on health insurance so you get
real competition instead of a
politically anointed competition you
know I live in New Jersey we have nutty
regulation there I can buy virtually
equivalent policy neighboring
Pennsylvania half the price that I can
in New Jersey third of the price in
Wisconsin
yeah it's illegal for me to do so I can
buy a car in Pennsylvania House in
Wisconsin illegal for me to buy the
insurance why nationwide shopping so you
see that gecko on TV peddling auto
insurance haven't peddle some health
insurance and at a good price to equal
tax treatment if businesses get a tax
deduction you're an individual unless
you're self-employed you don't get a
deduction equalizing how about real tort
reform how about removing barriers to
making it easier for people to combine
together to buy it get to get real
competition and people say what about
people with pre-existing conditions and
the like well why not start to really
build on what states have but really
haven't exploited yet properly and that
is high-risk pools you can't get it you
go in the pool yes it's subsidized but
states that have high-risk pools have
far lower premiums than states like New
Jersey where we demand mandate that you
have to cover everybody and well if you
allow nationwide shopping I guarantee
you're gonna see companies rise up it'll
do this more cheap than the current
carriers today because they're wedded to
the old system where they offer you true
catastrophic coverage where if something
bad happens to you you are covered they
won't cover you if you need filling but
if something bad it's like like housing
insurance homeowners insurance if your
house burns the company then doesn't
come in and say sorry the policies
canceled because it's a you know it's
past December 31st
you know the policy's expired no if it
happened in December you're covered and
you're covered until the house gets
rebuilt but yet within health insurance
if you say get a dread disease during
the year policy lapses at the end of the
year how crazy is that that's not real
insurance and if you reform the system
you can get the best of all worlds true
safety nets but true free-enterprise
creating more health care more for
will cost it's a bottom line this is the
big battle over statism we get it right
in this country sound dollar good tax
code put a rein on regulations and get
the Constitution operating in that area
again get real free enterprise in health
care well we've gone through today will
simply be a nightmare that we quickly
and long-term wake up from thank you
thank you
thank you we we have we have a few
minutes for questions if you feel you
want to go or have to go please go
I'm of an age where I'm very sensitive
to that but raise your hand if two
people here row with microphones and
while you're thinking of questions just
let me give you one example among
zillions of how regulatory agencies will
always regulate more and more EPA the
Journal had a piece there the other day
that the EPA is decided that they must
have oil spill regulations apply to
farms and ranches and they've declared
milk as milk spill comes under their
regulations and oil why you can't make
this stuff up a percentage of animal fat
which is a non petroleum oil is how they
define milk so if you're at a dairy and
Betsey kicks over the cow I know they do
it by machine now but I'm being trying
to make a point that means you have to
have first responders you have to have a
cleanup protocol and the and then the
Agriculture Department has several
million dollars set aside and this is an
exact quote to help farmers and ranchers
comply with on-farm oil spill
regulations I can't make this stuff up
as the article says it's amazing ok mr.
Forbes I come from San Jose California
and my econ teacher actually told a
story about you he said he met you in an
airport and he made time for a
conversation with him and actually sent
him and an email afterwards so my
question for you is do you have any tips
on networking in leadership for the
young people here glad you asked
two years ago I co-authored a book on
leadership called power ambition glory
2% all for cash but but but but
seriously seriously on on networking in
this day and age the fantastic thing
with all the tools you have that's why
the Tea Party movement became so strong
it's also why Barack Obama won those
kisses in 2008 where this wasn't the
genius of the people running his
campaign who is a people coming together
through the through social networking
that won those caucuses that Hillary
Clinton ignored so the tools are there
for anyone who wants to use them but
it's very easy to do and they still have
something called libraries now you may
have noticed they have a thing called
card catalogues so in the old days if I
want to look something up I have to go
physically there and go through the
thing and then hope they have the bloody
book in the library maybe three months
later if they don't they might get a
copy and now he go on the internet more
and more it's instant you can do and I
was mentioned I co-authored a book on
the economy about to do another one you
can do research that would have taken
years to do literally in now in a matter
of weeks or months it is phenomenal so
networking just do it and put out there
the Facebook's a nice thing throw it up
there everyone has friends and it's a
like-minded folk it's very easy fan
pages and the like to a come in contact
very quickly and so it's much easier now
and you often learn something now
defriending is another whole another
subject which I'm sure the writing books
on but we won't get into that now and in
terms of leadership
one of things that makes for a good
productive leadership obviously is
having that sense of purpose and winning
the trust of others and also if you
desire to be a leader recognize no
matter how good you are no matter how
wise you are no matter how energetic you
are you're gonna have crises you will
make mistakes or events will hit you in
a way you hadn't anticipated it happens
so be flexible it's what you're here to
do you get exposed to a lot of areas you
never know when you're gonna have to
draw on them and so be prepared for
crises it will happen and if you will
have that mindset you'll save yourself
one heck of a lot of angst and trouble
oh what did I do wrong why didn't I
foresee it get over it
it's gonna happen
we have time for one final question and
we would also like to inform you that
mr. Forbes will be available in the
lobby signing his book how capitalism
capitalism will save us why free people
on free markets are the best answer in
today's economy Thank You mr. Forbes
very much I understand why my father
read you every day of his life to
question the wise daughter yes thank you
why 100,000 as a sealing and why 17%
instead of 10% I'm sorry to ask more
money questions but no 100,000 sealing
400 on and the other one was on why 17%
okay let me do the 17% on the flat tax I
wanted to do it in a way in which no one
when we brought the system in had a tax
increase so yes you could lower the rate
and do away with the exemptions but a
lot of people with the crazy things are
done with the code would face a tax
increase and I just don't want to get
into that so let's not let the mistakes
of the past hobble us don't don't let
the perfect get in the way of pretty
darn good so I would design the thing so
that everyone gets a tax cut no one gets
a tax increase so we don't get hung up
politically on that the other thing as a
part of that is you have to give people
a choice when you say people ask you're
gonna do with charitable deductions
you're going to destroy charitable
institutions you can explain knowing the
70s when the top rate room went from 70
to twenty eight chatter we're giving
went up when people have more they give
more in this country you can go through
all of that people just focus on what
they lose it's human nature so when you
bring in the new system give them a
choice they can go at the old system or
stay with the old if they wish if people
know that if they want to keep what they
have they can boy the temperature goes
down just removes a lot of political
roadblocks and emotions so you decide
which one is better
okay let's try it because I don't like
it I can I've got to gotta let the steam
off so that so the 17 is what have
worked out as those numbers I'd probably
have to update them now and the terms of
the hundred million on regulations I
picked that just because it's
destructive and I think politically is
what we can get through now as they
stopgap to starting to have do some real
constitutional work on that and I see
that as a beginning not as an end once
once once elected representatives know
that the trend line is more
accountability they're gonna move away
from this tendency of saying I'll pass
something that sounds nice and throw it
off to somebody else slough off the
responsibilities no if you want to go
into public life better be prepared to
take on real responsibilities that's
what it's about like anything else in
life well as was indicated I'll be down
signing books and let me say again thank
you for your kindness and warm welcome
Thank You Larry for my free dinner thank
you